heute kann keiner sagen dass das nicht
einfach die geilste grafik ist die
gemeinsame zypern hat sich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video feature
im mittel eingeblendet geht weg gameplay
ja freunde ich habe meine mode
runtergeladen die gt ab 15 86 also von
der grafik her und wendige vorne im
hautbild wem wir schon hier hat sich
jetzt nicht sonderlich viel verändern da
wir den allgemein hey girl wir sehen
allgemein der wandel von mit dem baum
china taschentücher auf dem tisch es ist
alles ein bisschen kontrastreich ja
liebe mutter nämlich reddig motorola
alter das ist schon krank
vielleicht kennt ihr so im normalen wenn
man diese nicht installiert hatte die
nachteil relativ unspektakulär aber
jetzt gerade die zeit sich mal alle
lichter spiegeln sich in den autos und
so sieht einfach nur noch krank aus wie
mein kollege spielen ja das ganze licht
wie viel geiler aus also wir warten
jetzt einfach mal ab mittag in einer
natürlich wollten wir nicht ob wir schon
die zeit einfach ein bisschen vor wie
jetzt einfach mal weg und den jetzt
schon okay
die sonne geht jetzt gerade auf alter
aber dieser sonnenaufgang sieht einfach
todes geil ausleger die bekannten
lichter und ich weiß nicht ich verlinke
euch mal hier oben hier oben
gta video was sich vor einer woche oder
so zenker hochgeladen habe wo ich euch
den viertels bild gezeigt habe da habt
ihr noch gta gewinnen ohne qualm grafik
mod einmal gesagt können sie einfach mal
drauf klicken und dann kannst du dem
video erklären
das ist auf jeden fall schon enorme
unterschiede und ich würde sagen wir 100
mal richtig geile kari über das menü
tina widmann klare die hybrid variante
ist aber kein burrito mal irgendwohin
und rücke entlassen
die seit alter gesetzt und jetzt einfach
mal einen punkt hier vorne an den strand
hier zum wendet beach und fahren jetzt
einfach mal dorthin und vorne an wie die
grafik da vorne 11 weil ich glaube
gerade am strand ich bin nicht der beste
autofahrer sieht irgendwie aktiviert
weil man wieder fahren wird gerade nicht
so entspannt hier auch die gasse zuletzt
ihr mann als er gutmann
ich wollte nur zum brannten strandbar
anhalter schwede warum sich in alle ihr
tagestief davon wie man ihren kern rein
fahren also ja leute ihr seht schon dass
es nicht geht hier weckt natürlich weh
täte effekte sicherlich trauten aber
diese redford soll halt irgendwie das
gefühl rüber bringen dass man ab ok
alles klar
reddoxx motto ein bisschen das gefühl
rüber bringen dass man sich in gta weg
befindet und ich finde das ist schon
alles klar
vollkommen legitim nicht buchen so
diesem ort bringt und wissen dass wir
über wenn man sich in gta weg durch
diese grafik an alter das ist ultra nach
ein paar sekunden später
ich habe aber ich würde sagen wir nehmen
vorne einfach mal diesen fh oder ferrari
world glaube ich darstellen und vorne
sind die tarife auf kinect ab und von
hinten einfach folgen eine mischung gebt
euch diese grafik freunde.de
geisteskrank manchmal vor
automobilhersteller würden kooperationen
eingehen die beispielsweise prix mit
nord stream auf einmal so regenjacken
und so fast alle krank werden wenn auf
einmal audi mit mercedes irgendwie so
einen sportwagen machen würde
[Musik]
es geht ab alter irgendwie war die
polizei gerade auf zivile wie man
wirklich in amerika gerade hier wir sind
aber gleich von am strand angekommen mdk
die sonne
hey das ist ja nur noch heftig gibt euch
einen bentley hier alter das ja auch nur
noch geil also hier lang und jetzt links
abbiegen der wir ob wir hier war
überfordert gerade hier genau hier vorne
befindet sich in guter freizeitpark
dahin kann keiner sagen dass das nicht
einfach die geilste grafik ist die jäger
das ist ja nur noch krank hier alles
also wir vorne davon einige weiter von
aber ich habe gerade dabei sich hier
durch freunde könnte platz machen
dankeschön sie aufmerksam von euch
gefahren jetzt einmal vorne direkt zum
kunden und stellen jetzt mal den ferrari
hier absteigen mal ein alter schwede
ich kann da nichts sagen ich meinen gibt
euch allein die wellen wie krank ist das
bitter gerade die sache ist dass das sie
gerade die originals preset sind von der
mod alte regional auch volker die vorne
ist alles komplett normal wenn die sonne
untergehen wird und hier vorne bürger
gerade nur die original preset von
dieser mod also die sache sehr guter
körper auf jeden fall
unter wasser wie das ganze sogar noch
viele kranke auf sie kann nicht
auftauchen
wie kann ich auftauchen dicker teppich
auftauchte bin ich dumm wie kann ich da
noch mal auftauchen gte klasse dran ein
brot zu kommen konnte hat das jetzt
gerade leider nicht geklappt hat zudem
bot in roberts schönen sonnenuntergang
habe ich mir gedacht ich schnappe mir
ist einfach ein spinner und liege
einfach mit dem finger nach vorne hin
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wo die stehen
aber ich glaube in gta gab es vorn auch
noch irgendwo so gaedt die ihre dass
sich einfach an diesem ganzen orten hier
schon war er feiert gerade voll wir
landen jetzt einfach mal entspannt auf
das hat auf jeden fall super
funktioniert zumal jetzt bin ich
unterdrücke weder schwimmt er nur nach
vorne ich halte die maustaste gedrückt
werden und auch da er aber wieder nach
oben schwimmen wie schwimmst du nach
oben an
hiermit boxt er hier mit boxte auch
space leerzeichen fisch geboxt google
jetzt mann du musst mit der maus
richtung oberfläche navigieren und dann
mit links shift anfangen zu schwimmen
darf mit dem titel klappt nicht so ganz
geklappt hat habe ich mir gedacht ich
nehme jetzt normalen helikopter wir
wären schon die sonne direkt wieder
unter mottaki kann ja schief ich werde
jetzt versuchen bis den samstag zu
landen und ihr vorher auch schon
auszusteigen direkt am wasser und jetzt
kann ich dann geht nicht so nach oben
gehen und jetzt mit schrift nach oben
schwimmen okay ich bin mit dem was
dartmann da war mein helikopter dahin
nicht dort zu dem ich wollte aber ich
hoffe ich komme noch bevor die sonne
untergeht warum schlimm ich überhaupt zu
einem boot ein fucking sieht menü oh
mein gott freuen ich hab's geschafft ich
habe mit den jungs wieder geholt
deswegen schon nach vorne und andere
segelboote es ist einfach nur krankheit
ich mein gebt euch die grafik tägliche
vorne die wolken das rendering von alle
möglichen sachen die wir party für die
lassen und sagen ja ich versuche einfach
mal die segel wurde hinter mit den
programmen ort wahrscheinlich berg hier
stehen und ich bin durch die luft habt
ihr bock darauf lasse ich mir öfter gta
5 grad ich weiß dass games von den 1000
jahre alten jeder youtuber davon schon
unzählige videos gemacht aber ich habe
einen schock und dann kann ich irgendwie
oder max oder in den schnappen dann
zocken wir das zusammen glaubt man
leichter und schreiben gta 6 in die
kommentare
köln gefahren jetzt einfach mal auf den
sonnenuntergang zu hier hinten freunde
ich stell mir das soooo cool vor mit
seinem rennboot thema zu fahren ich bin
damit durch den ort gefahren oder voraus
schon mega geil aber dieses ding ist ein
komplettes stadtteil wie native grafik
bitte freunde das ist einfach nur noch
ihre kugel diese fahrräder diese wette
geladen wenn ihr einen geilen pc hat
dann ladet euch auf jeden fall die
beraterkosten motto war doch immer für
gta ladet euch die mod für gta 5
das macht euer spiel sommer von viel
geiler wenn man sich die motto unterlegt
hat man quasi von riesigen ordner mit
neun verschiedenen versionen wie vorhin
schon gesagt habe ich hier die
originalversion drin ist geteilt noch
für ultra version und zum die hürden
auch laufen auf meinem gibt derzeit
ruckeln ich meine gerade läuft alles
mega plötzlich keine komplett hin und
her gucken das alles megapixel auf dem
flughafen verbringen nur wenn die
aufnehmen
ich weiß ich habe mittlerweile oft genug
gesagt wahrscheinlich da hinten an das
richtig dunkel oder leuchtet die stadt
und hier vorne es einfach noch so diese
sonnenuntergangs licht eine sache gibt
aber noch nicht nennen wollte und
verbräuche dafür hat man flugzeuge wo
das ist ein flugzeug ich hab gerade
plain dran stand weil ich heute da vorne
auf das flughafengelände und wollte
einfach mal schauen wie die grafik
gewinnen wenn man hoch weiter in der
luft
aber das komplette teile kombiniert
nicht gedacht ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal mein tipp genau um hier vorne bei
dem flughafen quasi auch gelände zu
kommen
das sieht schon mega geil auch
wesentlich mit verbotenen schnell april
china bringt ich dachte das wäre nur in
der geheimen militärbasis gott geschieht
dafür dass es unendlich werde ich machen
will triple hier anlass hat jetzt bin
ich pausieren dem flughafengelände und
werde zumindest nicht von den getötet
dazu ständig die zeit ja auch noch mal
ein bisschen zurück einfach mal
umzuschauen wieder quasi ist wenn ich
mir wirklich sein
der flugverkehr war bitter auf ja da
sind die teams am start ich will einfach
mal wissen was passiert wenn ich mir
wirklich das flugzeug könne also
irgendwie sollen was habe ich denn dafür
hin ich glaube das war genau ihren cargo
player alter spitze deshalb noch eine
fette flugverkehr ich will einfach mal
wissen was passiert wenn ich jetzt
wirklich wird zum fetten flugzeug hier
irgendwie abhebe und dann quasi in der
luft bin und einfach mal schauen was
passiert wenn ich war sie mit schnellen
geschwindigkeit sie ihn hoch aktie hoch
gestuft ich will einfach mal wissen was
passiert wenn ich jetzt mit diesen
fetten flugzeug beispielsweise so mega
schnell über die stadt flieger doch der
in welche länder fehler auftreten oder
alter einfach aus jene fucking großstadt
los angeles luca das ist ein fucking
großstadt ich bin so hey alter vorige
die sonne unter wir haben das in meine
spuren übrigens egal am himmel da hinten
haben ein anderes flugzeug aber wir sind
bettega wird der los angeles
international airport
wir haben hier vorne das stadion halt
schon mega geil hier gerade das
ultrabook einfach mehr gta 5 laden also
vorne lag man leichter weil ich das
machen soll
und jetzt noch mal thema quartier wenn
ich jetzt wirklich nur knapp zwischen
ähnlichen hochhäusern hierher fliegen
also ich merke schon dass wir gerade bei
mir noch relativ gut läuft natürlich
vereinzelt druck lassen und da bin ich
beispielsweise einfach mal irgendwie so
makulatur das ist natürlich auch logisch
negativ weiter hoch alter die scheite
hoch man oh my god freunde david mika
okay ich wirklich gerade irgendwie so
ein bisschen komisch und die teile herum
fliegen
strömungsabriss super gemacht franklin
also ich würde wirklich sagen beschweren
kann ich mich normalerweise eher weniger
das war meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen ich habe einfach
diese gta wächst grafik mod redding
runtergeladen und hab ich einfach mal
installiert das game bietet auf jeden
fall mega krank aus sicht von gta weg
können wir noch deutlich andere sachen
erwarten
aber ich würde wirklich sagen wenn ihr
bock darauf habe das nicht mehr geht die
hochladen auf meinem kanal vielleicht
damit anderen youtube an schreibt man
geht ja weg den kommentare lassen mike
da und jetzt wo wir können jetzt im
kanal abonnieren oder jungen meinen
checken jetzt für andere videos in
berlin und auch und könnt ihr auf die
glocke klicken dann bekommen die winden
habe ich die jungen
[Musik]